the emmy for lead actress in a drama
series
hold on
[Applause]
cheers to this history-making queen i
just feel very lucky zendaya is
officially the youngest ever two-time
acting winner at the emmys as she takes
home her second award in a row for
outstanding lead actress in a drama for
her role as roo in euphoria season two
means so much thank you thank you so
much wow um
to all the incredible actresses in this
category i'm so honored to be beside you
thank you to the incredible incredible
cast of crew of euphoria thank you for
making such a safe space to make this
this very difficult show um i love you
all so much thank you to the academy
thank you to my friends and family some
of which are here tonight um
thank you to sam for sharing rue with me
um
thank you for believing in me the 26
year old goes on to share the number one
wish she's had for euphoria as she
thanks her fans
my greatest wish for for euphoria was
that it could help heal people and
i just want to say thank you to everyone
who has shared their story with me i
want you to know that anyone who has
loved aru or
feels like they are a rue i want you to
know that i'm so grateful for your
stories and i carry them with me and i
carry them with her so thank you so much
we make way for the two-time emmy winner
crazy it's so special you know it's such
an honor you know to be uh acknowledged
for something that you're really proud
of yeah um it means it means the world
to me and also like i'm so happy for so
many of our you know more behind the
scenes folks getting so much
acknowledgement cinematography and
editing and it's it's really really
special they deserve it so much they put
so much into this show you know that was
real cute but what you gonna do tonight
where are you going not much i'm gonna
do a little wardrobe change you know i'm
gonna do it you know do a little
two-step and then head on home because
i have work i gotta get back to work so
um i'm just gonna
take it easy you know i'm gonna have an
easy night okay you didn't shout out tom
was that night no no no no he's part of
my loved ones see
there you go there you go
how is 26 so far what did we do for 26.
26 i just i was just chilling yeah i was
chilling with loved ones
[Laughter]
and it was really you know it was really
special i just you know i just
i think it's uh time moves so fast
sometimes you just gotta like chill and
for my birthday this year i just was
like i'm just gonna chill like i'm not
gonna do a thing because i always am
doing a thing so you are a thing so it's
all good you are a thing and the moment
and all of that we're so proud of you
yes congratulations so incredibly proud
of you you go have a great time tonight
make that phone call and go have it
right
with your loved ones
with your loved ones
[Music]